as we have it right now with the current
personality disorder categories
histrionic personality disorder is
probably the most controversial some
people believe that it is narcissistic
personality disorder light so sort of a
less
um obvious a less
um malicious version of narcissistic
personality disorder
um and I think that will probably get
sussed out if we do move to a more
spectrum-based approach because then you
would be describing sort of a
personality disorder and then you would
add the traits to it so you know with
issues and interpersonal functioning and
and Etc so you could be a little bit
more
specific rather than having to just put
somebody in a category so that's where
things are moving you're saying that's
where things are moving well cluster's
based view of NPD anti-social
personality disorder to more of a
spectrum with personality dysfunction
than you you list the traits that are
there and I think that'll be more
accurate as especially there's so much
overlap between these personality
disorders right now especially cluster B
it is not uncommon for people to have
two or three personality disorders to
meet criteria for two or three at the
same time so speaking about borderline
personality disorder and histrionic
personality disorder
um borderline personality disorder can
best be thought of as a disorder of
instability and impulsiveness
emotional instability instability in a
person's self-identity sense of self
instability in a person's relationships
and then underlying all of this is an
intense fear of Abandonment histrionic
personality disorder
is more of a disorder of emotionality
Dramatics and attention seeking
this you know histrionic disorder
typically is
known for The Dramatics and people who
are observing or interacting with
somebody with this disorder may even
feel themselves almost kind of wanting
to turn away there's a sense of play
acting as the person is speaking or
engaging with you
um
something just feels a little bit
disingenuous
and a lot of attention seeking similar
to borderline personality disorder you
might see with histrionic personality
disorder attempts to manipulate however
the motivation with history on it
personality disorder is that attention
whereas with borderline personality
disorder the underlying motivation for
almost everything is to avoid
abandonment so you'll see frantic
attempts to avoid abandonment frantic
attempts to keep people close and those
frantic attempts can be really harmful
to the person and to others
to the person themselves
so the fear of Abandonment can result in
the very thing you're afraid of right
and and I there has been some research
also to suggest that there that
borderline personality disorder has
different types as well
um
and I think this is really important
because in my own work I have
encountered many people with borderline
personality disorder in my own life
right
um
and there are different types right I
I'm thinking specifically of a girl I
really love who I've worked with for
years who is so self-aware about this
and endearing and uh
she she owns her I can forgive
almost anything if somebody just owns
their
um she is she might lose her temper she
might lash out she can be erratic but
she will come back and apologize own it
and accept full responsibility and not
only that but identify it and make
changes
she doesn't want to be harmful I adore
that about her I think it's an admirable
quality more of us could have
um that's very different than
when you think about it there are nine
different symptoms and you only need
five to meet criteria so depending on
which symptoms you have you might be far
more calculated conniving manipulative
or you may just be more of the impulsive
kind of messy emotionally erratic type
and so there's some new research also
coming out that's even suggested that
among women
those that score higher in some of these
more calculated traits of the disorder
may actually be it may be a certain
presentation of female psychopathy
yeah are are some of these personality
disorders again probably impossible
question to answer but
how much of it is nature how much of it
is nurture or how much of it is in the
genetics and you just can't do much with
uh maybe another question a different
way to ask that is how much can you help
that how how much can you become better
that is a tough question so there's been
a ton of change in the way we've thought
about the etiology of these personality
disorders specific to borderline
personality disorder I think in general
the view is that most people believe
that it was associated with neglect or
trauma in childhood
while there is a correlation there
there's a correlation between that and
many mental health issues not just
borderline personality disorder we also
there is evidence to support a genetic
basis for this personality disorder and
there are people who have borderline
personality disorders that report no
childhood trauma or difficulty
um and I've and I have seen I you know
sometimes things just happen so
I think it's a mix I think we need to
think of it as bio psychosocial which is
generally the answer to most things when
you're talking about how a mental health
issue comes to be
I certainly think that in most cases
and here's just me speaking personally
again I think in my own work in most
cases what I see is that somebody may
have some sort of predisposition then
they go through certain life events and
uh learn patterns of Behaving that may
serve them well as a child in a
dysfunctional situation but end up being
very problematic later on or they just
have enough hardship that that Gene
whatever it was lying dormant that
little borderline personality disorder
Gene expresses itself and you'll see
that with things like schizophrenia
depression anxiety disorders there tend
to be certain ages where you'll just see
that expression happen